how did you get introduced to lord of  the rings when you i think you said 13  yeah how did you find it it was because  of dungeons dragons there was um  there was a  a coveted dungeon dragons game among my  little middle school friends and um  where is this where are they here in los  angeles oh and los angeles and um there  was sort of a sort of required reading  list  for the game and uh  yeah and  on top i actually read them out of order  because i didn't realize there was a  hobbit book that  that preceded it so i read lord of the  rings first not really it was a box of  books so i didn't i just sort of grabbed  whatever is on top  with me and hold me tight all through  the night you're shining bright i'm your  host the baby you're my  [Music]